hello and welcome to episode
153 of the gamespot after dark podcast i
am your host mohsein joined in the
studio once again
by
the one the only jean-luc zeitge
hello we have headphones now i can hear
my voice it sounds very professional i
added the one and only because i saw you
pick up the cup and i was like i gotta
delay this
[Laughter]
also joined by jordan remain what up
what up and lucy james hi also hang on
it's very clear who is the favorite
because we've got one and only and then
just us two i know you didn't pick up a
drink that's why i added the one and
only i literally just explained it
you can't drink from the magic eight
ball the game spot magic eight you
probably could it just would not be good
for you you would almost
what do you think that blue liquid
tastes like
this is how the tide pods
uh lucy hi i'm gonna i'm gonna every now
and then i'm just gonna throw a question
for the magic eight ball at you and
please chat if you have anything yeah
chat if you have any questions for the
magic eight ball
um
let us know and we'll do our best to ask
it and see what it tells us
lucy james
can you ask the magic eight ball yeah if
yeah
bayonet f3 is going to be a good game oh
okay wait
is gonna be a good game
i'm getting the asmr in here too okay um
it did the thing where it just it
it kind of went on the edge it's nothing
is basically cocked
it's done it again
oh god this does not want to answer this
question it's done it
okay okay
big money big prizes
what i'm talking about big money big
prizes according to the gamespot branded
magic eight ball that we found on the
free table in the uh office kitchen i
put many things on that free table that
was not one of them
branded magic eight ball is absolute dog
[ __ ]
don't listen
don't listen i will say that as a
gamespot employee and i'll say it loud
with my chest did we ever sell that like
no i think i think this was for um an e3
party that we hosted um yeah and none of
it made sense i remember shaking it a
few times and being like this is not
good for asking questions because it
gives you like random things sounds very
cheap too yeah i mean like the blue
liquid it has i know we've been kind of
messing around with it since i found it
10 minutes ago uh the blue liquid has
bubbled quite a lot and it means that it
is actually quite difficult to read what
is on the magic 8 ball
but nevertheless we will persevere
all right let's get into the portion of
the podcast where we talk about what
we've been consuming as content
consumption people
i've been consuming this
jurassic
world dominion um
diet dr pepper have you seen jurassic
world absolutely [ __ ] not no no no
no i do not want to watch it well what
have you been consuming oh that's a good
segue i uh i watched all of the
leftovers
okay
very sad every episode every episode
none leftover
how sad does it make you because i don't
know if i'm looking to be sad right now
don't
i like really spanish that's my secret
captain i'm always sad
so first of all it's only it's uh 28
episodes so it's not even like a huge
investment it's half an enemy it's half
an enemy i um i watched the final
two episodes on sunday night um
obviously you know you've got the sunday
scaries you're coming back into work and
i'll tell you one way to get over the
sunday scaries it's just to cry it out
sat alone in my apartment
give yourself the sunday sads yeah give
myself a sunday
i was just in
flood like genuine floods of tears
so uh i would say it's one of the best
tv shows with one of the best finales
i've ever seen
um
but maybe yeah so it's sad but what i
have been playing uh in terms of actual
stuff i've been consuming i've been
playing some power wash simulator i did
it on stream on tuesday tam joined me
along with fadrim and a nanobiologist we
all just played some powerwash sim it's
a fun game that's a really fun
satisfying game i don't know why it's so
good you know exactly why it's good
as as someone who frequents
like pimple popping videos but also i do
watch a lot of power wash videos on tik
tok the algorithm has really honed in on
that have you got the pool cleaner guy
yes he's incredible the pool guy pole
cleaner guys i have no idea what they're
talking about
i do know that go to tick tock and find
all youtube and you can find people that
will do like incredibly satisfying
menial activities there's a guy who will
clean pools and you just get to watch
him clean the pool do you know how dirty
pools get yeah he is he is amazing
because you see this [ __ ] swamp get
turned into an really like pristine
looking pool and it's like how will he
do this and it's like this this water
looks
black how is he going to do this and he
like will throw like a tablet in there
and it will like just bubble up and then
condense all the garbage into one small
thing that he just scoops up and pulls
out and you're like witchcraft so he's a
witch yeah but power wash simulator it's
it's just
it's exactly what it says on the tin
it's one of those simulator games they
you kind of you boot it up and it goes
here's a really filthy van and he is a
power washer and then you just
thought was that summer game fast wasn't
it i want to say it might have been
there
that might have been a person power
washing
that was just someone outside um but no
so i was playing it and um you can
obviously take the approach that we were
like kind of [ __ ] about writing in
writing in the grime
or you can take it very seriously
getting make sure you've got the right
nozzle for the job use soap
be like me hack the game and
accidentally get unlimited soap what how
did you accidentally what's your name
yeah so basically when you clean bits to
like 100 you get money and then you
and then you use that to buy soap and
different things you could also have
different outfits
very important for washing stuff so it's
it's uh it's fashion suds
i guess fashion
fashion sods instead of fashion souls uh
but no we were playing it on on stream
it's a very fun time it's in it's on
game pass now so it's like free but it's
been in early access for a bit and
i just didn't expect it to be so good
yeah it's so satisfying it's really
satisfying it's out now i think yes
it should be out now um it's on game
pass on
xbox and pc yeah and on the cloud if you
want to really take that
you can't power watch the clouds
how many
uh multiplayer how much is it six but
six in in like the special modes yeah uh
which is where you have the really
really big um things to watch so we were
doing a fountain that was massive
there's also a mini golf course or
whatever um but in career mode it's only
two okay yeah but they do the really
cool unpacking thing where you you know
whenever you've unpacked your room in
unpacking it shows you a little gif of
you just
very satisfying does that in power wash
them you know
telling my friend group right now yeah
that i placed up with yeah let's just we
should all do this yeah let's let's play
power simulator we're doing it on
unprofessional friday yeah i think so
we'll do that oh yeah yeah yeah i'll be
on that one so yeah
yeah get it downloaded i need to i need
to see if mine goes to 1.0 because i've
got the early access version does it do
cross-play yes
um
uh
it is a really good podcast game
and also a stream game so when i was
playing it i was watching lucy's stream
where she started playing it and i was
already playing it yeah i was like great
i'm watching someone play power
and and then we just combined to the one
power simulator and we cleaned the hell
out of that fountain
except as i remember like stepping back
and we'd completely missed like one
massive chunk of it yeah wait so like
when you're when you're watching
something does the game eventually say
like oh you've cleaned everything what
it usually does is like if you start
with a car it breaks out the individual
parts of the car into their own sections
like door panel left door panel right
bumper pub caps and when you clean apart
it will do like between 100 hubcap okay
and it will let you let you do that and
it's also got a button where if you hold
it down it will show you where all the
grime is
like yeah and like what generally what
it does is like it will give you the
you've completed this
section at like 80
but then you can really like carry on
going and getting the nooks and crannies
which is what i'm all about i cleaned
that first van
until it was perfectly
you also have a super human jump which i
really like
you can also crouch and go prone yeah
like it's quite it's got the like armor
like as you when you crouch the little
uh image in the corner goes into a
crotch and you press prone and it goes
oh the enemy animates into it can you
get like underneath the car you can't
get underneath you can you can the
little rafters of the what do
um but yeah it's so good to like pop on
a podcast and just like just clean away
and also or like watch a stream in the
background or all that kind of thing
that sounds great it's really really
satisfying really enjoyable it's out now
so you can check it out but
um yeah i i'm i haven't tried it on
console you're playing with control i
was playing with the controller yeah i
was playing with i'm an elite gamer so i
play with mouse and keyboard
and it lets me really get into the nooks
and crannies is it game pass yes yes
getting better get your ass on game pass
you know that's what microsoft says and
that's what you should do about game
catalog
what are you talking about
that's the name
that really showcases how
terrible playstation is at advertising
welcome to game catalog
simulator is it even coming to
playstation if you're naming your
service
the way to figure out whether you have
got a good name for your service is say
the name
in the same in the quote for welcome to
jurassic park
yeah because if it sounds good welcome
game spot
well well like pass implies like you
think like oh like a fast pass at like
disney you're like i am paying to have
fun
catalog sounds like a magazine yeah or
like oh like i'm going to go to the
library and there's like the decimal
system's going to be there the ladies
going to pull the little cards and i
don't know
and i'm like that's not as fun one of my
favorite things ever in the world was uh
skymall
and that's you know r.i.p skymall i'm
gonna google it just to feel something
again
but that's gone now oh well it's all
online but it's not the same as having
the catalog like i want to have a
full-size replica of tutankhamun
sarcophagus and i want to be able to
order that from the comfort of the
airplane that i'm on
oh an automatic pet feeder
uh yeah but it's it's a fun game it's a
good game it's worth checking out
especially if you've got
game pass
because it's free
game pass
[Music]
that's how it works uh lucy can you ask
the eight ball um where the bayonet is
naive angel mode will make me a better
gamer these are going to be vayner
themed question
says hydra ox okay um
oh is that the mode where they uh
[Laughter]
absolutely halal mode will what's it
called again angel mode this is called
halal mode
what's it called
naive angel mode
will naive angel mode aka halal mode
make tam a better gamer no not me i'm
already a good gamer i'm the best gamer
i'm talking about hydro knox okay we'll
make it same question will it make hydro
knox a better gamer
come on big money big prizes
uh no it was a capital n and like seven
0's
i'm sorry i'm really sorry unfortunately
so just enjoy enjoy the
you know what upside is now you can get
to see bayonet as bits
yeah you get skin no she has she has um
hair covering it i think there's bits
where
she's she's showing her flesh a bit more
which is what the naive engineer tasted
oh no i saw that i saw the gif she had
she still had hair yeah it's like very i
think that was the nintendo safe for
twitter yeah like i think oh okay and
miyamoto being like just putting this in
here so no one can see those nipples
um
what else have you been checking out
lucy a plague tale innocence oh yes
because uh you were talking about
plaguetale requiem a couple weeks ago
and i realized that i never played a
plaguetail and it's free on playstation
plus and i was uh just you know when
you're so overcome with choice
and i just booted up my playstation and
playstation was like hey here's a free
one for you
okay
uh and it's really good i really enjoy
it i um
it's a lot and i don't mean to sound
dismissive it's a lot better than i
thought it was gonna be
the story is really good i really like
the way they've kind of
nailed the brother-sister relationship
although it is technically like the
entire game is pretty much an escort
mission it doesn't feel
overbearing in that way and i i don't
know the puzzles are inventive and i
like the way that it just kind of
presents every little area
it's it's a very deliberate game yeah
and i really enjoy it and um i'm up to
chapter
12 of 14 so probably gonna finish it
tomorrow yeah i i've played it at the
weekend and i just kind of been
um i'll see what i've been doing i've
been using playstation help because i
barely ever use that um
to make sure i get all the collectibles
because i want to get the platinum
because it seems pretty
achievable yeah it's pretty achievable
if you're like working towards it on
your first playthrough if you realize at
the end you're like i [ __ ] have to
replay like this level in this level
chapter select though the playstation 5
though i don't know if it had that one
that came first i remember it
it's got chapter selection but because i
remember being super annoyed when i got
to the end i'm like [ __ ] i ain't missed
something back in like chapter three
because it uses a single rat has escaped
it uses the activity cards so you can
even just pull up the thing and hit the
hit square and it takes you that feature
just abandoned wasn't it like
it's because not everyone does it but
the ones that do use it like use it
really well like souls i think had it
demons although all the launch stuff had
it i remember astros playroom had it
because i used that so oh yeah that was
really good
um spiderman had it and that was cool
because you could uh use it to like
immediately fast travel to like a
certain like a thing that you actually
couldn't do in the game which is kind of
weird but like i don't think horizon had
it how are you a first-party sony studio
not possible i don't know for sure like
don't forget first party studios i feel
like that's the thing i thought that's
where herman health should like kick in
the door and be like i need to have a
word with all of you right now and just
take it off his belt
time for a beating
how to find
how to use the
game i'm just trying to find if there's
a list anywhere but
there isn't sadly but
yeah i've been enjoying that um i'm
gonna finish that and then
i start mass effect was free
on the old um
amazon gaming i love that you're acting
like you don't own mass effect like
well now i own it
i can play mass effect
again after years of poverty
i just i just brushed my hair behind my
ear and this came off yeah the um i'm
sorry these headphones are i think
jordan has these
good headphones the rest i had those a
few weeks ago and like i remember just
taking it off and then going back to my
apartment being like what the [ __ ] in
my phone just like all these little
pieces of we have no money okay we've
got no money
we are operating on a shoestring budget
of hopes and dreams this is what our
headphones i mean have you seen this
have we ever talked about for like the
the chat the live chat about this desk
and why there is a a giant piece of wood
on this desk why is that i don't even
know that well i know
oh my god
you know what maybe
maybe that'll
we can make that like a special reveal
like one day if we get to like uh like a
stretch goal
i think that's gonna be an incredibly
disappointing review
it will but that's it's gonna be like
years
yeah we have been actively trying to get
this out of here immediately yeah but
you've also been saying that for like
three months now
you know
we have no money okay we've got no what
makes you think that next month we will
have money
well jordan
john luke and i are planning
a heist okay mm-hmm we're going to play
you're playing gta online going to local
wells fargo
and we are going to clean them we're
going to head over to ign's office yeah
and just steal their headphones
she's [ __ ] injured has plenty of
headphones
headphones i'm sorry you are acting like
we don't have
millions of sets of gaming headphones
lying around like come on there's at
least 10 right next to me
yeah in this office you are never more
than six feet away
[Music]
does have like five headphones richard
has like headphones for no reason like i
don't know why phones are just that he
plays like his music or whatever he's
listening to over like
the headphones that have the most insane
amount of bleed on him
um but yeah so yeah i've been playing
playing that and then uh what else i've
been doing
oh uh i'm hyper fixating on the sims
again
um
oh yeah i dodged covey that was good
continued to we left though
i
yeah
i mean i was talking to my doctor and i
was like do i have long covered and she
went you haven't had coffee so now
important version of cold and she's like
well you need coverage you need to get
one before you can't skip the skills
yeah
do you think it's
allergies because i feel like i've been
having like weird just like
like my throat my throat's been like
real sore lately for like a really long
time and just like constantly stuffing
away and i think it's like allergies
this year i don't i've had a thing for
like the last few months so this is kind
of a culmination that but allergies wise
i had to take my cat to the emergency
vet yesterday because she had
what i thought was a tooth abscess and
then i get there and pay 200 for them to
tell me she's allergic to something oh
no and i have no idea what it is so i
have to get like a new oh no yeah
so just something in your apartment you
just don't know what it is no idea what
it is so also the vet
um it was a new vet i changed a change
vet because the one the one that's right
next to me is really really busy and
takes like two weeks to get an
appointment
i went up to a new one which i love
they're really great with my cat i can
get an appointment same day or next day
it's phenomenal
i went in i had a new vet looking at
peanut
and she she was like
talking away and she went you know i
know i haven't seen peanut before but i
do recognize you
as in me no no but me being british i
was like oh i can't possibly ask her if
she meant to say that to me or she said
that she just recognized my cat so i'm
just gonna ignore it i love the idea of
your vet looking directly i can't gain
you know i've never seen you before but
i do recognize it
and i was like
is she talking about peanut is she
talking about penis she can't talk about
me and now it's just haunting me i was
like where does this vet know me from is
she a gamer if i said she could be a
gamer just singing
a bit but you know
this is vet if you're in the chat let us
know or i guess dr adams mom kind of
funny yeah you've been in a lot of
places yeah i know but anyway peanut
it's fine
she knows she's fine they she has put on
a little bit of weight she's like 15
pounds now
how much is that in dollars
oh my god
she's meant to be like 12 and i think
it's because she knows i'm an easy mark
because if she starts like going
i'm like okay oh yeah
have a treat oh it just takes me wow
yeah no i'm i'm
i'd be doomed if i was a parent like
i'd be like i'd be like baruch assault
you can't have any candy but mom please
i would be baruch assault's dad
um but anyways that's all i've been up
to been sick sick cat
rats
rats and crying
sounds like a solid i promise i'm not
depressed
at least one of us isn't jesus jury's
out jury's out
jordan are you depressed uh wait magic 8
ball is jordan remain depressed
no no
game over
you want a trigger warning what's going
on
all right jordan's gotta be put on a
watch
oh my god
i've been playing the other game that is
on game pass starting today escape
academy
which is
an incredible time especially if you
have someone to play with yes i have it
downloaded 100 play with uh another
person like i if you
want to play it on your own or you have
to play it on your own because you have
no one else to play with that's fine the
game is fine but it is
leagues it's leagues better with another
person like why didn't jordan do this
because he put this sassiness into his
and you denied me and i rolled up with
my editor and i was like
now it's all coming out go on get it but
it was
i
playing this game solo feels like like
what what's a game that's like designed
specifically like for
multiple people like apex legends
those are two very different examples
you can play you can play apex by
yourself yeah i guess uh it's kind of
like uh it would
it's kind of like
um
kicking a ball against the wall
sure but it's more fun when you kick it
to another person and they kick it back
yeah we'll go with that example it's
like kicking
the ball against the wall by yourself as
opposed to kicking it with another
person i don't know who's gonna die
i don't know man i love kicking a ball
against the wall on my own i don't need
other people i'd have to rely on other
people that's a back of the box quote
yeah
escape academy it's like kicking a ball
against the wall
uh
yes that's a great example that is
that's a perfect example says among us
which is
if you're playing among us
[Laughter]
single player one person starts up among
us they'll never find me
[Laughter]
but it would be terrifying if you were
like fixing everything up and then all
of a sudden like stuff started going
wrong and you're like
you're just in there on your own someone
calls a meeting and you're like
well yeah no escape escape academy is
dope it's definitely gonna be i think on
my top 10 by the end of the year um it's
it's
emulates what it's like to do like an
escape room very well like it's the
first person 3d
point and click uh space and if you're
like playing with another person you can
do kind of that thing it does it split
screen so you can just like see what the
other person is uh looking at um which
is just so much easier for all the clues
i'm telling everyone please just play
with another person i don't understand
why there's a single player option i was
gonna play single player then
that's what i was like
it's like don't don't listen to the
hacks that kind of funny greg miller
doesn't know what he's talking about
he's like
he played it on his own and he's like
it's totally fine if you play by your
own like no it's not are you lying to
your audience like this
that man has a child
a business
a wife
maybe just it was all sound those places
all sound like people he could have been
playing yeah that sounds true
i mean
anyways gregory loves sucks to be you
man
according to jordan remain yeah
apparently
never get invited back onto kind of
funny games
i wasn't going to be invited on anyway
because i you will
well i i
talked [ __ ] about the ps vita the last
time oh yeah
who don't know what is this game and
yeah yeah escape academy is a game where
you're just uh playing as this person
who gets invited to the escape academy
which is like the place where they're
like oh yeah we train like the future is
like spies and hackers and presidents
for whatever reason it's like thrown in
there too um and like all of the
pop quizzes and like classes and whatnot
all take the form of escape rooms i mean
you're trying to collect 10 badges over
the course of the year in order to
just prove that you're the best in your
class
almost none of that matters it's like
very neon white vibes where you're like
after a while you're like i just want to
do more escape rooms like the story's
kind of just here as set dressing to
like just kind of remind me why i'm here
and why i should
care to do the escape room but like the
escape room is just fun so it's like why
wouldn't you just like go on to the next
one
they start getting
really hard after a while not like
the witness level of hard but like in
the
way where you kind of like face this
problem you're just kind of like staring
at it for like two minutes it's like the
answer's right there i just need to
wait does it have a timer yeah um
almost all of them have time or some of
them have
creative
variations of the timer but yeah for
i think the longest one is
a 45 minute timer
okay i want to say and the shortest one
i think is 10
minutes
um but yeah like there's not a lot of
replay value here and i would just tell
people like if you're getting like short
on time like don't bother uh there's a
hint system where like someone will be
like hey maybe you should do this don't
use the hint system like just try to the
best that you can because like the
escape rooms are kind of like one of
those things since there's no rng it's
like the
same levels like like i replayed one
level just to like see like oh i wonder
if it's changed and i'm like no the
answer is exactly the same it's like a
30 minute escape room my second attempt
took me 10 seconds to get out and i'm
like so
um it's just one of those things where
i'm like just let the timer go just try
to figure out the best you can um
dave and i managed to get a plus on like
all the escape rooms that we played
together on first try like not to humble
brag or anything but like just putting
it out there
like what happens if you
fail it does it just move because in a
normal escape room if you fail you just
get let out and you're just ashamed and
sent on your way but
is it like a retry
yeah it's essentially like
like one of the escape rooms is you the
janitor accidentally locks you at the
bottom of a tower that's quickly
flooding and so like the timer is like
tied to the water slowly going up and
it's like oh you drowned
but it's like oh don't worry just uh try
again and uh go back to the you drive
beginning
they took the the creator said they took
inspiration from my hero academia and
they're like designing a school where
it's like the students are just up to
crazy dangerous [ __ ] like on a near
constant basis but everyone's like no
this is this is totally
normal like
there's a gun going off over there the
student almost drowned there's poisonous
gas in the vents these are just things
that happen we're still in my hero hero
but yeah it's it's it's a dope game and
everyone should definitely play it with
a friend and not by yourself because
that's the sub-par way to play full
review up on gamespot.com now hell yeah
what else you've been checking out i do
that uh volleyball game i was talking
about last week
i
kept playing the
demo and i'm now 11 hours
wait it's a demo for a game that's not
out right that's not alex
i'm only playing the demo i'm not buying
it
volleyball game it's called spike air
volleyball and
uh welcome s-p-i-k
a-i-a-r
um
and it's just i want to say it's these
like two or three dudes out of like
france or something like that who uh are
just like
huge high q fans who are like there's no
good volleyball video game so we're just
going to make it and i'm like this is
really really good all the patch notes
have like little like uh references to
like haikyuu and stuff like that like
they were like oh you know like one of
the coolest things in the anime is that
hanada's able to like see the block and
like hit the ball off the person's block
so you've now added that into the game
so if the blocks in front of you you
don't feel like all is lost um and like
they seem really passionate about the
project and uh
i think they're like
trying to get the full game out in early
access uh this year where it's gonna
have like this story mode where like
you're recruiting different people of
different strengths and uh like you
train them up to get stronger and you're
like
rising in the
world tear facing off all against these
opponents and
i mean oh they look so happy in a demo
spike air volleyball spike air is
s-p-i-k-a-i-r
i'm i'm on spike volleyball no spike
volleyball
it's like
it's there it's whoever made that game
was like we're gonna make the fifa but
like for volleyball and
it's
it's not even up to like fifa standards
which is like already really fun
when developers are like we're gonna
make a fifa version it's like fifa
wasn't just one game that they made and
we're like we did it it's like they made
they've been making fifo for one billion
years and they've been making
incremental improvements every single
time so you're not just going to roll up
and make a fifa like you're going to
make a [ __ ] game that you then need to
commit 20 years into
but no one's wondering this looks cool
though yeah i've i've been having a
great time with it they're
already like trying to think about
how they could improve it in a quote
unquote sequel or expansion because a
lot of people are like hey could you add
like these sort of attacks and stuff
like that and like ah that would be like
too complex in a 1v1 setting because
it's designed that you control the
entire team on one side of the court so
they're like maybe in the future we
would make like a sequel to this and it
would be like 2v2 or something like that
but for right now we just want to get
like this game out and with the
build that we have it just doesn't we
can't figure out how to make it work to
add a
uh
2v2 setting uh right now which maybe
will change but like i've i mean i've
had 11 hours of good time with the demo
so far against bots so
i mean like i would love to see more
about this um if only
you worked for a video game website that
was capable of writing some sort of
feature if only if only my job allowed
me to seek out these people and
ask them if they had more details to
share
get on it sounds like you're being lazy
i want an interview with these people by
next week jordan remain
i need to find
chalk abyss
and see what they're up to that's a
[ __ ] dope ass that's a developer
but yeah get in touch with them let's
just do a feature on this yeah it's
happening live we'll do an audio logs
yeah
i don't know where that pc is i don't
know it's literally right next to us
like playing with this audio logs back
on the menu yeah i was like what should
we do this and richard's like i should
just like put it on a desk and use it
and i'm like oh yeah
i'll use it i'll draw some stuff on
there okay yeah let's do it but
seriously maybe you should reach out to
them and see if there's anything we can
do cool with them oh yeah i mean like
volleyball games seem very underserved
and it's not a [ __ ] joke is that fun
of course it is a bug
uh what else anything else uh no that's
that's it for me okay cool
jean-luc
um i
they've been playing a game that i can't
talk about um
do you
okay for real though are they do you
think no are they absolutely
did you play alex i i need to go back to
playing i'm going to play alex i'm going
to play half-life alex tonight okay no
you're not don't
bet that was so
you were like doing nice
it looks like you just
took some drugs
the camera's offer for just long enough
turn around you're like
no um yeah i i need to finish alex yeah
i had that thing where i got the uh
oculus quest too and like plugged it in
and i had a bug in alex where every time
i raised my hand it had her hand and
then the gun overlaid on top of it okay
yeah and it was like really immersion
breaking yeah just like the hand and the
gun independently moving and i was like
i hate this i can't well without
spoiling it the ending of alex
is like sets up
three in a way that's like i swear to
god valve if you then ghost me for
another like
decade
could you imagine though that there
could be a moment in time where
someone's joking about like oh i am
playing something i can't talk about
someone's like oh is it half-life 3 and
in the back of their mind they're like
well actually yes
could you could you imagine if they did
make half-life 3 but they had to
incorporate the steam deck into it so
you were wearing a [ __ ]
vive headset oh that would and then
i yeah love it if it was like uh breath
of the wild where you hit the menu
button and
uh gordon raises a steam deck
that'll be so good
it just raises it and it's [ __ ] hello
gordon
oh [ __ ] this guy again
um yeah
that's a game you haven't been playing
yeah that's a game yeah you haven't been
playing but you can't talk about yeah
can't talk about the game i've been
playing
i haven't actually been playing much
else um i have been watching
tooka and birdie have you ever seen oh
i've not seen it but i do love um
uh
because they they were originally on
bojack right yeah some of the people
from bojack um
and uh it's i'm watching the second
season so
before we begin before we carry on
magic eight ball is half life three ever
coming out oh [ __ ]
hints at gamespot
whoa do we have the reveal do we know we
just launched an arg
go go to gamespot.com and see if you can
find out anything inside see if you can
find some hints about half life three on
gamespot.com
oh yeah anyways carry on
so glad we found this
if you go back to our like our game of
the year video for alex like it's like
oh like did you see that rob blinked
three times
somehow
only three times in this 30-minute video
uh yeah watching tooka and birdie if you
haven't seen it it is excellent if you
like bojack horseman i highly recommend
it if you like um
i feel like ali wong um who it plays
birdie if you love her like comedy like
i
highly recommend it
so
the first season was on netflix and then
netflix said nah we're not we're not
making more of this
netflix saying that they're not gonna
make more of something netflix [ __ ]
counting their animation wow so then
uh adult swim said yeah we'll pick it up
and i was like excellent i'm very
excited to watch this um
they aired it
on cable only last year and i was like
what are you doing like
can
i would like to watch this show i don't
have cable and they're like
like to be fair like the the i think the
adult swim account was kind of like look
we know like
this is all like
deals made in advance we can't do
anything about it so it finally
aired on hbo max like three weeks ago
the second season which is like a whole
year after it's been on cable and just
like two days ago they started airing
the third season also on hbo max though
so i'm like midway through the second
season they're like hey season three's
happening and i'm like sweetie i'm not
even done yet binge binge binge uh it's
really good though it's
it has that like same kind of bojack
horseman where it's just like
very funny but also gets extremely real
in a way that you're like oh god this is
this is a lot um but
it's all like female focused and um
it gets into some really heavy subject
matter um especially that first season
uh the second season as well it's
i would give like a fair warning like
because it kind of touches on some stuff
but i also think like the stuff it
touches on is like really cool and it's
like like wow i've never seen like a
piece of television like
talk about like
um
just like uh like issues with like
partners and like sex and stuff like
that like it's really good so um
without getting into like specific story
details but it's it's really good it's
insanely funny it's got this amazing art
style that's kind of like bojack
horseman but even like weirder
um
because
unlike bojack because bojack has humans
in it right yes like diane
yeah this is like all
anthropomorphic animals so they live in
like bird town and it's just like it
seems like the most
insane like there's an episode where
they they're like oh we're gonna go
visit um
for a bachelorette party we're gonna go
to this this like special island and
it's this island where all the people
there are like plant people
and it's just the most insane
looking like i don't even know how to
describe it like everything there is
just like made out of plants and there's
just like
these like pole dancing strippers but
they're like heads or venus fly
traps mean
so if you're into that
it's a good time love me some poison ivy
uh toucan pretty highly recommend it
it's uh yeah it's really how many
episodes season you know um i think it
was ten
each and they're only like 22 minutes so
yeah okay cool pretty easy pretty easy
uh speed through so man highly recommend
it but it's kind of all i've been doing
like i didn't
georgia was gone for the weekend and i
was like time to get stuff done and then
i proceeded to do absolutely nothing oh
a dirtbag weekend i love it yeah i
didn't know i didn't feel good about it
though because i really did like
actually like want to do stuff and then
i was like
yeah
that's what happens when you when you
become an adult you spend most of your
time thinking about things to do than
actually doing them me i have i have
like
i have two pictures that i bought framed
just
up against the wall in my bedroom
for about three months oh yeah i have a
stack of stuff that i've got framed and
it's just in my living room yes
just leaning up against the wall like i
bought more frames the other day and
they arrived and we put more posters in
the frames
frames add it to the pile add it to the
frame piles
frames are expensive uh we bought these
two off of etsy
and they were they were
i think they were like thirty dollars
each i haven't bought to buy it
i was able to get the exact size i
wanted the exact color and i was like
you know what for the price it's yeah
i'm getting exactly i just want to go to
a place where i can say here is my pile
of art frame it cheap pete's mate
michaels is that what cheap people
does that yeah that's what um that was
so nice those are nice that's 12.99 um
tell you what's really good to get on
etsy plants
juliana put me onto that i got a
massive um
like a big fern type thing for fifty
dollars free shipping i just got at the
home depot nearby i wish i could listen
i've got i've got a nice little plant
shop that i go to a little
oh i do like that one uh is that on
um
hyde i think like it's it's it's like a
little corner shop
no no no no it's not okay you talk about
plant therapy yeah yeah
thank you there's there was one nearby
thoroughly you don't live anywhere near
that place by the way i was like
inducting you i was like
i go to your place
like go to your place and it is a
considerable distance away from that
shop
um but yeah i i want to go i didn't know
chi pete's did that yeah but i just want
to go there and be like because i hate
finding i hate anything to do with
numbers okay and like a plant not plant
uh like frames that i'm looking at it's
like 12 by this i'm just like oh
if you want a really nice frame there's
actually um like a like a really really
nice frame shop uh right next to uh the
office
uh
next to where uh cato brian's was
that's where i got that witcher poster
framed like
this is like you want like a really nice
no you want you know you're trying to be
i just fancy no i'm just trying to get
all my all my
[ __ ] done guys we have a recommendation
from one peter brown
in this yeah
he says buy frames from art to frame
y'all also hello and then he followed up
with donald i would call him cheapy
the one only peter brown the thing that
i just said i wanted i don't know if you
heard was like i don't want to be
involved in the selection process i
don't want to be involved in the framing
process i want to take my artwork to
them and be like black frame
uniform for all of this please and then
just give it to them and i don't want i
want to be able to get all that stuff
back and be like cool it's not going to
cost you one million dollars you're um
very lazy like that's not
and your batman posts are framed very
nicely yeah i did that
well yeah
do the rest yourself it's painless
because i've got like eight different
things that i'm saying okay oh arthur
frames is a website and it looks very
handy thank you peter which
automatically to frame
frames or frames yeah if you have any
recommendations for places i can go to
oh no this is a website yeah
do not get frames from michaels says uh
sir 5000. no michael's is bad cheap
pizza is what we're currently looking at
what i'm calling louis what about a
framing stream oh god that would be a
nightmare i could probably do that i now
have like
seven cameras in my uh your setup is
um but that camera is specifically for
lego building so i'm sure it can make it
happen and you can it can't be used
um but yeah but how do we get to frames
i was talking about
buying frames and then not hanging them
up
if i didn't do like put all the frames
up that i have
uh
we could ask um
will lucy and john nick finish hanging
all their stuff up all their friends i
can't believe you guys even have them in
frames like all my posters are just on
the floor like not even framing it's the
way you're supposed to put posters it
says
consult gamespot
that's why we asked peter brown gave us
the gave us the place to go so
um
uh you're just putting your posters on
the floor that's not
you know you can just buy a carpet you
don't have to construct one out of anime
that's
a friend of mine um
their partner had a dining table and
they got loads of
cover yuri's time old comics and sort of
put pages on that's [ __ ] sacrilegious
not like not like
popular old like not old like collectors
items or anything just like comics that
they weren't reading anymore and then um
put sort of like a mod podge thing over
the top and then a glass on top
so they've got a really nice kind of
custom table i went to a bar where they
um
the the bar top was like covered in uh
old video game cartridges but
specifically they were video game
cartridges that were all um like
busted like okay like they got them from
like a place that was like these are all
trash none of them work because
apparently like
people they have to say that all the
time because i guess people would come
in and get really mad and yell at them
like how dare you do reservations and
they're like no we didn't okay
i'll just be like [ __ ] off get your own
shop
get your own shop and then you can
decide how to decorate it [ __ ] i do
like i think um ikea does them now where
they have these tables where they have a
sort of indent in the middle and then
the glass top so you can put a
collection in it
and but you don't have to do anything
like pour oh no epoxy or anything on it
yeah
um i finished playing a little game
called metal gear solid 3. why did you
put little accent on a metal gear solid
i just pronounced the r by accident
metal gear solid that's how i would
normally say
but um yeah i finished that game i
streamed it
round
bang
that's my she does the meow i do yeah
i don't want to get your username wrong
gia underscore rum jrum yeah
that was a really cool fan art yeah they
did a picture
[Laughter]
but yeah that game still rules um oh my
god my last dream was
it was a nightmare but i did it in four
streams uh still that game still holds
up i did a pacifist run
and then the last stream i played like a
bunch of it
and then got to
the escape the final escape oh yeah
which is like on the on the motorbike
and got to the final no no there's a
motorbike in it time yeah there's i mean
you've seen the motorbike many times
already
um but there's the bit where coffee is
if you don't spoil this the hovering
enemies up here
those [ __ ] like i tranquilized one
of them forgetting that one you
tranquilize them they can no longer fly
so they come like crash into earth and
like like it came down and just exploded
and i was like
[ __ ]
i accidentally killed that person so i
like i was like
when did i when did this game
when did this game last start prompt me
to save because i wasn't manually saving
because i know that game well enough
where i could just be like sprinting
through most of it oh no and it was like
literally two hours
did you see the
devastating
speed run during the summer game
um
super mario sunshine because i guess
like the way that game that runs
optimize you don't save and the guy just
like died during the like one of the
floodless levels where you run around
and just was like it was two hours into
the run so he's just out then no no he
was like he was just like
what do i do yeah and they were they
were like
like
god bless the person next to him on the
couch was just like oh no it's fine
we'll just start we'll just start over
and he's like uh okay and i was like oh
i feel so bad that happened to zeus
during one of his runs for bloodborne
where he was trying to do something and
he kept like not landing it and it was
like one of the most entertaining things
i'd ever seen because zeus is obviously
like oh yeah incredible anyway yeah that
guy just knows how to just he's just
like turning shelter content he's a
showman yeah yeah and like it made for
really really fun viewing but me i
tranquilized that dude and it died and i
had a meltdown on the stream i was like
but then like i went
like i had to start from the vulgar
stuff onwards and like you could like i
was playing and doing like i'm gonna
play this
for time saving so i'm like quick
switching and people are watching are
like this man is playing out of pure
anger right now like i was like
destroying
where like
i was fighting them and they were unable
to move because i was pummeling them
with like different like
items and [ __ ] and it's like stuck in
place and then like got that done um but
i had to like that turned into a
six-hour stream because of that one yeah
so like tam messaged me something and
then i thought he'd stop streaming yeah
and then later on i just got text which
was just
just finished streaming at like 11 000
but it was good it was good it was it
was a lot of fun so i finished that game
that game still holds up um
interestingly sorry someone in chat uh
joseph harbin i fell asleep near what i
thought was the end of tam streamer when
i woke up three years three hours later
he was still playing
basically
uh yeah that was a wild time but it was
fun and then i got into the the final
fight which i won't say what it is and
thank you um and like there was some
sort of slight delay between the input
and um and like the thing that oh yeah
the cqc stuff that you need to do yeah
and i was just getting rolled and i was
like what's going on here and i waited
to test it and i was like okay there's
like a second delay or a slight delay so
i was like inputting it a little earlier
it happened sometime i think it's cause
like i'm running it through
an xbox which is going to an elgato
which is going through a pc and like
something at some point is like freaking
out i also
it happened with security i remember
this might be like more of a speed
running issue but i remember like
someone during a speed run of three
saying how because of the way the hd
version has like higher frame rates than
the game is meant to that it can
actually like kind of break the game in
some ways so it could have been doing
something wrong it constantly feels
slightly off to me yeah where like
it feels weird and like the timing on
stuff feels weird like i was getting
annoyed not annoyed but like the fury
kept catching me a bunch of times and i
was like i don't remember being this bad
at this fight um
but it's also been a really long time so
i could just genuinely be bad at it um
but that was fun and i got it finished
and now i'm just like what do i play i
was like i started streaming and i was
like what can i play now i finished
metal gear solid one two and three on
the stream so i realized that i hadn't
played the resident evil 3 remake
oh
yeah okay i i like and i think it's
because
i heard kind of like a lot of not great
stuff about it
yeah a lot of people were like
especially come and i think this is part
of the problem is that they were
following up resident evil 2 remake
which is not only which is fantastic
it's just incredible like it's it's like
one of one of those games yeah it's like
one of the best resident evils like
hands down yeah oh two is in a fantastic
game but like resident evil 2 remake now
stands as like one of the all-time
greats of video games not just remakes
oh yeah or video games yeah 100 and like
i think a lot of people expected that
again from three but the thing about
three is three i really loved when i was
younger three is a very different type
of game from resident evil 2 og as well
it is like
i think a lot of the criticism i i felt
i saw around the three remake was like i
was very guided and it's very like
linear and it's very action focused and
that's kind of how that game is few
levels yeah
that's the more egregious part of these
that they straight up like the clock
tower's just gone yeah yeah
come on yeah so there's chunks of it
that i'm missing and it's a little more
action focused and i also like i wanted
more of the mr x stuff it makes so much
sense to turn nemesis into that like he
should function like mr x because and he
does if you think about it mr x
functions like nemesis exactly
if it feels like a weird reversal yeah
yeah whereas now he's like hello it's me
nemesis and then you're like i don't
like this very much rocky they have like
one section of that game it's like the
where he is chasing you and it feels
intense and then like
never again does not happen it's all
scripted in it so it's so disappointing
but like i i
installed it and luckily it's on the
steam sales like 15 right now and i was
gonna play it last week when i was like
i fired it up in playstation store and
it was like fifty dollars and i was like
no i'm right um
it's also like ten hours or something
isn't it it's like super short it's
pretty short oh you shorter than that
yeah you'd be in like six hours yeah
so i was like i'm gonna try is this
feels like the right price and
i played like four hours i was having a
great time with it like i had like it
was really it's not a bad game and like
you get jill joe's great that model for
jill is like
someone is a very into making jill look
as hot as possible like without making
like i must say jill is kind of like the
hottest guy in the fridge
so like this is why hentai exists
she's hot but she's not like they
haven't done the weird like pervert hot
thing where they're like oh we've made
her boobs really big and her ass is good
no she's just like she's like she's like
she's like very attractive but like
she's also like she's roughed up and
she's like getting a bit sweaty and
she's like kicking ass and you're like
this is just
good
yeah i was gonna say carlos
he's also an insane himbo and like yeah
he's also very creepy to her immediately
like he's very like he's flirting with
her too hard the way it's like you're a
bit weird man i don't like it and also
like how did he get into that like
military position with a haircut like
that i it makes
you know in scrubs where jd invents the
hermit it looks like carlos he's like
every scene they cut to him and his hair
is just like fully in front of his eyes
and i'm like it looks like firing a gun
with like
yeah
but he's also like immediately he sees
joel and he's like oh you're very hot
and you're like
come on we were all very attractive we
were all thinking it man you didn't have
to say it out loud voice what's going on
you're giving the game away
um but otherwise yeah it's it's it's
been enjoyable uh it looks really nice i
like that they introduced the dodge like
the made the dodge mechanic stuff yeah
that stuff's really cool um and i've
been like nipping about and i went into
the toy store that's got a mega mega man
in it that's the big giant life-size
mega man i was like i just want the
helmet or at least give me a surfboard
helmet so i can pretend it's dead rising
again um but yeah i'm like a few
um i was into it maybe two or three
hours into it um and played it with
stream and like
uh sphere hunter came through and like
was just like chilling out there and
like i was like oh [ __ ] no now
yeah
immediately i got bitten by a [ __ ]
three zombies in a row and i was like oh
okay
jill is her favorite character yeah the
original version of three is her
favorite game exactly that's a lot of
pressure yeah but like i was i was just
having fun with it where i'm like i play
that game where i try not to shoot
zombies i try to like skirt around them
uh-huh which is what kind of series
but like the zombies in this game like
they laundry they're aggressive
and some of them you shoot them in the
face and they're just like
no i'm just going to carry on walking
we've been trying to reach you about
your car's extended warranty
ridiculous the um the nightmare mode in
that game is also really good i've not
tried that yet i don't think you unlock
until after you beat it but like they do
actually like mix up enemy types and
stuff in a way that feels yeah like
pretty cool for like a new game plus i
think i'm gonna
i'm gonna finish it and i'm i need to
jump back into resident evil 4 um vr oh
yeah mainly because i miss i miss the
loop of shooting a zombie in the leg and
it falling over
kicking them pull out the knife a good
melee attack that's what i've been
missing from the more recent resident
evil games like i like it when you shoot
an a zombie and they just like topple
over but in these games you shoot them
in the leg and they're like
i might ouch my leg and carry on walking
yeah and you're like oh god yeah yeah
two and three it's like there's like
that perfect like i frame you gotta like
find where it's like okay it's just
gonna dodge right there yeah and uh but
yeah i've been enjoying it it's fun
it'll probably be over very soon
um which is fine for me and then
hopefully by then like something else
will have come along that i can check
out
um but yeah that's what i've been
playing mainly i did start leftovers as
well because um you also want to be sad
uh that's my secret captain i'm always
sad but also
i think you'll like it because you can
see
season season
lost season one is very very different
season two and three is where it gets
linda luffy but it's like you can see
him go from lost to leftovers to
watchman
yeah like yeah i think i was i was like
missing lost well i was missing uh like
prestige tv because i'm watching
westworld and
oh
i have not heard a single person talk
about it other than that that's true i
haven't heard anyone talk about
anyone talking about season three either
they were like covered in westworld for
like two or three seasons yeah i think i
remember coming to gamespot in like 2018
and like yeah right west
we were doing breakdowns yeah and then
season two and then season three like i
barely heard anything about and then
season four i saw it on hbo i was like
crystal i'm gonna describe season four
as it feels like they that uh it's moved
to the cw like oh it is
bad i i don't want to move to take i
also like especially this is in the
light of how marvel has been apparently
treating their vfx uh artists and stuff
um
the vfx work in some parts of westworld
season four is abysmal
there's a point where i think it's in
episode 102 where a fire starts in a
cabin and i was like
why is that yeah what is that free thing
is that a free
thing that you got from uh like youtube
with a green background and you've just
like the plugin effect
but there's another bit with a train and
it's meant to have like a dust around it
i was like oh is that gonna
it doesn't make sense anymore and it's
not interesting the saving grace for it
is they've got um ed harris oh he's
putting in words still he's carrying
that show on his own like he's
incredible as i think evan rachel wood's
doing rachel wood is good as well yeah
but her character but her character is
like she's
very strict like her character works for
a video game development place and
she's in some sort of weird like
a plot that feels like it's
might have been rejected from riverdale
and it's just like
oh come on whereas the ed harris
character feels connected to the old
stuff
more and like as an actor ed harris is
incredible and he's got like a mystique
to him and he's scary and he's also like
like very threatening and like he he's
carrying that show i feel like so i'm
like tuning in for him but every time i
start watching him like also the [ __ ]
aaron paul's haircut isn't saying that i
don't know what is happening with his
hair what do you mean he's like describe
it
i get a picture of him i'll say someone
needs a picture you should look at i put
a picture of him on twitter and i was
like what he's like i got he looks like
his hair was cut so it could be like
moved to the side
like you know like a comb yeah swipe
kind of like mine but instead he's just
wearing that's not real that's real
that's not real that can't be real
that can't be what they went for
oh so whoa
it's very weird
it's so strange that is
for audio listeners it's really bad yeah
yeah he was like give me the spider-man
3 haircut oh my god it is
but the thing is as well it's like
the thing that's bugging me about it is
i always loved in old seasons of
westworld where they would kind of do
little throwbacks to the original park
um but there's stuff in season four
where it's
if i have to hear maeve's [ __ ] this
is the new world you can be anyone you
want to be speech one more time i hate
maeve as a character now
well because that's like surprising she
was pretty good and like they've given
her powers and it's completely
inconsistent and it's just like
she's just she's become neil and it's
really [ __ ] like she's she's [ __ ]
i i think i i mean i think in terms of
just like she there's a bit where she
literally looks like a surveillance
camera and goes
yeah and then it turns off oh my god
they just like don't know what to do
with that character and so i'm waiting
for it to be that show should have ended
uh it should have ended
season two
season two i think season three they
kind of like kind of still was
intriguing now it's just like like
unless unless something happens that
really brings it all together in the end
but even even i don't know
bernard and stuff i'm just like
yeah there was a time when a character
would say freeze all mortal functions
and you'd be like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
stuff's gonna happen everyone's gonna
freeze all my functions and no one's
listening to them and like it's like
what's going on
the main the main problem and then i
promise we'll stop bitching about
westworld the main problem is that
they are still relying so heavily on the
anyone can be hosts thing but now it's
so easy to turn someone into a host that
every time someone is mysteriously a
host it's like well yeah of course they
weren't like
everyone is at this point this is not a
surprise anymore and i am really sad
that i'm missing the genuine surprises
because in season one it was like well
is is bernard a host like i i don't
understand what's that what's the deal
with this kid like and the timeline was
all over the place and it was
yeah yeah and like season one of
westworld felt like season one of lost
to me or early lost where it was like i
don't know what's i don't know what's
real i don't know what's going on what
is it so well done
like behind it and i was craving that
and i started i watched one episode of
leftovers and i was like i'm getting a
i'm getting a vibe that something is
being season one of leftovers is like
because they had a book to go off and
that's what season one is season two and
three when lindelof is just doing his
thing yeah
there is an episode called like
international assassin or something
which is just the most lindelof thing i
think about the scene
but i like it because it's like
it doesn't belabor the point it's just
like you jump into this kind of world
that like weird [ __ ] is happening and
you've got these people who
never speak but are just like chain
smoking constantly and you know the the
vanishing has happened and et cetera et
cetera and you're like okay so they've
got a lot of interesting mysteries set
up to kind of unpack everyone is just
perpetually depressed in that show
though like
yeah always there is a sad time for
everyone involved and like you're just
like okay cool um
but yeah i i started watching uh that
and that was that was cool um but beyond
that i'm i've been reading berserk as
well as always
i i had like a break away from berserk
for a little bit just because it got
busy and i was like oh i'm gonna i'm
gonna read another issue of berserk um
the other day i was like i'll jump in
bed read some read some berserk i was
reading until like 3am
i looked at the time and then i was like
oh my god i was supposed to read for
like an hour and and like books are good
manga is great yeah um
and yeah and that's
and that was it that's all i've been
playing um i also started playing point
b which is fun oh yeah you started
playing that one uh the netflix mobile
game
oh
how is that it's fun it's like one of
those games where you just kind of like
you only really need to flick and you
just kind of like it's like reversed
down well
yeah but you're trying to go up down and
it's like really fun
up well um you just kind of like flick
this little character and it kind of
like
it bounces up so you got like moving
from platform to platform and then if
you like
bounce them off a wall you'll do like a
little double jump and you figure out
new like traversal moves um and the
whole goal is like just to get up and
sometimes they'll be like oh you need to
to open this room you need to collect
three cherries and one coin but there's
like five cherries and three coins so
you're like there's clearly a right
trajectory i need to use to cur to kind
of like only collect the exact amount i
need or i need to mid air like readjust
or something like that you know how you
said is the opposite of down well it's
by the person you made down well oh yeah
okay i didn't know yeah so he may down
while he's like well yeah he just went
fighting
i mean one day he just like he grabbed
his phone upside down hold on a minute
yeah he dropped his phone he's like huh
but yeah that was fun um that was a good
time uh anyone interested in checking
out point b i've got it got it
downloaded i mean i guess it's the first
i've ever heard played a little bit um
do you need anything special with your
like a special version of netflix no you
just need to have netflix and then if
you open if you open the netflix app it
has like a bit of um like on the bottom
it shows you where
and then it just takes you straight to
the it just asks you to log in basically
yeah okay the apple store yeah i guess i
could try that then you probably should
because they're releasing into the
breach on there soon
oh really
into the breach is coming netflix right
that was announced oh
um this changes everything with new
content basically oh can i play that on
my ipad yes yeah you can
uh
damn you netflix
one of the best video games i think i've
ever played yeah
is phenomenal netflix is making moves
i'm like surprise like i think point b
is great like into the breach is great
um and they're like making a lot of
smart move they acquired that studio
night school i think they're making a
lot out of everyone who's been like
we're getting into games netflix has so
far done as opposed to amazon and google
yeah amazon rolls up and like we're
getting into games like yeah well at
least netflix seems to like at least
understand that like they can they don't
have to like chase like
triple a normal like they're
netflix is also being smart for being
like we're just attaching it to our
existing service that we know just
everyone already has like we're not
gonna sell you a box that you have to
buy i think it's absolutely genius that
they went to the interbrief team and
were like we want that and we want extra
content like that's that's like the one
sharing so good yeah like if they did
they should just continue doing that
where it's like find games that they
know people love and
refer you know kind of freshen them up
and then go and get new new games to
kind of support as well yeah what's that
one game that's coming out uh the the
her story guy oh it just got delayed
it did no that was supposed to be like a
week or two yeah it got delayed for liz
sam what's his name
sam barlow not sam watson which is what
came up when i uh immortality yes that
was gonna be on on netflix as well i was
like yes fmv games just put them all on
netflix slight delay just to end of
august yeah okay okay they're not too
still not too bad it's like a last
minute thing really bad yeah for sure
um yeah and so that's everything i've
been playing
i'm just trying to find the document and
then i realized that we don't have one
we don't have one
that's the end of that one that's the
end of that
yeah so
uh we don't actually have any questions
or anything like that lined up well not
like that but let me check in
let's have a look in the discord in the
meantime uh
dailybean31 in chat says raised by
wolves is so good on hbo that's only two
seasons as well sadly got cancelled
recently
um which is a shame ridley scott
um behind that one
um who you may know from
uh assassin's creed yeah the voice actor
maybe motion actor as well
oh
yeah very talented
um so he's in that uh and i've heard
nothing but good things about it so i
want to check that out as well
um but yeah any questions i've got a
question from ben b who is a person a
couple weeks ago who said started
listening to podcast back in february
and i'm only 10 episodes away so that's
another one uh are there any peripheral
devices you were hesitant to purchase
but once you used it became
irreplaceable which has the same cadence
of like show me a life hack
show me a life and uh that tick tock uh
as an example being i just bought the
mountain everest
max keyboard and now i struggle with my
keyboard at work due to the lot due to
the loss in comfort and ease of use to
the point i want to get the 60 keyboard
for work and travel i'll also i'm now
fully caught up if you were curious i've
got an hour drive to work so i tried for
at least five episodes a week hell yeah
wow
valiant effort thank you
um
the mountain everest max keyboard okay
i'm good this is someone have a picture
keyboard i don't know see i thought i
was expecting something small but this
thing is huge the mount everest max
keyboard you were expecting something
more like it was like i want to get a 60
oh no he was gonna get the sixty percent
oh look at this
mountain dot gee wow i think it's got
like dials in it on here
is this the steel battalion controller
what's going on
um
so it was the question what peripheral
is there like a peripheral you've picked
up that was like changed your life that
changed it earlier so much
i've got my keyboard my current keyboard
is i really like it um it's i got it's a
standard kikron mechanical keyboard oh
yeah yeah it found great it has
bluetooth
um on it
and also wired so you can wire it so i
have two computer setups a laptop and a
gaming pc
so what i do is i've plugged it into the
gaming pc it's not great it's not
designed for gaming but i use it for
gaming i'm only using a few keys and if
you're playing with me you just get over
the fact that you can hear me click
clacking um but like i plug it into that
and then i bluetooth it to my laptop for
work so i only have to have one keyboard
so i can switch between the two yeah
which i really really like a lot um yeah
i used to have two keyboard two
keyboards oh yeah yeah i mean yeah i
have like a kvm switcher that i just
like hit a button it just like boop
switches over from laptop to like pc
that's kind of nice oh wait yeah where'd
you get that from yeah what's up um i
think it was just on amazon it was like
30 bucks it's just a little little thing
plug in whatever usbs you plug into it
and then you just i just like uh use the
whatever that little sticky like velcro
is it a usb switcher um
yeah sweatshirt i think it's by like you
green
or something is the brand interesting um
oh god i don't want to add well green
usb 3.0 switch selector yes two can four
port two computers yep yep yep you
literally just hit a button switches
between my laptop and my pc change my
world also i'm looking at this mount
everest thing by the way it basically
has a steam button stream deck built in
so you can either four keys on the top
above the um
the num lock stuff and you can oh wait
wait it also features integration with
obs studio
wow what the hell now i want this
keyboard stream stream decks i do have
one incredibly useful i don't have one
at home but i mean i'm using one right
now literally just with no show
i mean they are so great they're so
expensive though they're like i get why
because it's like i imagine it's a
pretty pretty beefy piece of tech and
you can like do what you want with it
you can get the app there's a stream you
have to pay for it oh you can you have
to pay to use the app and i was like i
refuse if i'm gonna pay i'm gonna buy
the thing instead but also i won't buy
it because it's too much money no no
stream deck uh goes on sale every so
often yeah they have a white one now and
i was like oh that looked really good in
my white shutoff
no i got i got the mini and i really
really love mine
how was that just like six the six key
one or i think it's 12
oh yeah because i think they have
let's upload
wait a second does this kvm thing work
with any usb device oh yeah oh my god i
have um i have like why are you telling
me this so i my mouse uh or my keyboard
is a um logitech wireless keyboard that
i just have a little dongle but i just
put the dongle in there and it works and
then i can just
between the two because i've got two
mice on my table that i would love to
get rid of one off so oh yeah i know
because my mice is hooked up in there as
well same thing yeah yeah that's what
that's what i wanted to do
one of you after
um i have the stream deck mark ii
okay it's the one i have and i got that
i did not pay 150 for it though i think
i got it i think i got the last gen
version on sale
because they just launched this version
yeah this is the mark two yeah something
like 150 that's so much money but the
white one is nice but the light one's
really nice
so five thousand in the chat says tiny
keyboards off for perverts um wow i like
i would have
i have a 60 i really like tiny keyboard
like look i'm not an accountant i'm
never gonna use that number pad thing on
the on the side like get rid of it i
don't need it yeah same i used a 60
uh that dave had
from doing some uh hardware stuff but
when i was back in the uk and i was like
this sounds really good
oh this is this is some jeff bakalar
talk i feel like he's activated
somewhere he's just going to come out
and you'll talk about keyboards i got my
keyboard
[Laughter]
um but yeah that's a peripheral that
i didn't yeah yeah no yeah kvm switcher
especially if you use two different
uh computers highly recommend it the dj
hero deck
what are you using that for that was a
peripheral that i played bloodborne on
it or you know whatever i mean back when
dj hero was active i played a hell of a
lot of dk hero holy [ __ ] but that was a
performer i looked at i was like that's
never gonna work and then i got one i
was like this is great
we have one in the office and i really
want to hook it up dude do it uh we
should hook up like rock band and stuff
we must we must
i think we do i think we do that game is
so good so was it freestyle games that
made it i think
but it's so good why did they never make
another one they made two two they did
they made it they made the second one
yeah and then they just didn't do as
well
yeah i think also like by the time the
second one came out that's when like
guitar hero was also kind of on the
decline but like the thing was like they
created
their own remixes it was so good it's
only 90 bucks on amazon for the
turntable and the game
bundle
so good so good i think you could
probably play those on stream without
getting dmcad because they're so like
wildly remixed maybe i got i got a part
of my let me look at twitch and see
who's playing dj no one's gonna be
playing no one i guarantee you it's zero
magic 8 ball will there be people on
twitch playing dj hero
let's see
big money big prizes that means yes
and do you know about the obs function
uh where you can
uh specifically like take a certain
track and apply it to um like a uh
specific track in obs like like audio
tracks you can separate your audio
tracks you can do that and then you can
tell
twitch hey this audio track has licensed
music on it
and no and it'll automatically get rid
of it on the uh archive so you don't get
dmc oh i did not yes they have a
specific function for that because it's
not just like is that an obs level
function it's a function that works with
obs and twitch interesting someone was
streaming dj hero 2 five hours ago but
are they streaming right now that's big
money big prizes that's troubled chris
is he alright
he's playing cuphead now okay um yeah
the ending of my metal gear solid stream
got uh muted on on the screen because it
plays a song by star sailor
um i was amazed that my quarry
playthrough didn't get dmcad because i
just i i played the normal version i i
just played with like just like [ __ ] the
rules no i wasn't ariana grande was like
that's fine my friend my friend was like
don't play the stream version it's it's
crummy like it'll it'll just mute on
your vods did not and i've so i've just
got like the ariana grande version like
on my stream the music in that game is
absolutely bizarre yeah we talked about
that bonkers music selection all right
um
yeah that was dj is so good we should
bust out and yeah we should play that a
bit for fun maybe do a stream i'm
definitely down uh yeah any more
questions
uh no
that was the one that was the latest one
oh unless we do we do have like question
of the week in the other chat
yeah i want to start doing question of
the week although uh which maria over in
our discord we'll do a question of the
week so if we go down our discord
question of the week uh but i believe
this week's question of the week was out
of the week uh our
um
our segment last week where we were
talking about uh games that we
uh oh yeah yeah so so she did a q the
questions based on that so i guess we
couldn't really answer that lucy could
answer yeah wait what was the the topic
from last week i'm sorry i was sick it
was uh games that uh we hate that
everyone seems to love oh well electric
okay well
games that we hate that everyone else
seems to you hate not we oh
i hate that everyone loves yeah it
wasn't hate it was like a dislike
dislike um
i mean i don't like fifa
plenty of people love fifa yeah that's
an easy one too that's not cop-out
electric burgers said what's an example
of a game you tried for a while and said
[ __ ] it and then years and years later
went back to it and liked it for me it's
witcher 3. for me it's plague tale
because i played like two chapters of it
and then i bounced off and now look at
me
dark souls yes mine was dark souls dark
souls it was one of those i remember
playing it when i was like
12 years old and not good at like
you said that live on the [ __ ]
internet while sat next door really
i was it was definitely in middle school
wait in 2000 jordan dark souls came out
in 2011. you can't be no no no no you
were 12. i'm probably i'm thinking of
demon souls okay like that makes way
more sense jesus
the life just flashed before all of our
eyes and just being like this game is
this man's posters are on the floor
[Laughter]
also i love that this is using the
windows 95.
listen moving into a new place is very
hard and you don't want to do any of the
responsible adult stuff i i will have
been in my new place for my new place
for almost a year and i still post can
you call it
um yeah uh
you said dark souls the demon soul sorry
mm-hmm yours is demon souls of dark
souls mine was dark souls okay i
remember like trying it
getting
i think i maybe got to the um
what's it called the tourists no no no i
got past that um
capra flight town light town it was
blighttown and then i was like [ __ ]
this game um
and then i think what got me back into
it was uh
my senior year of college i was i had a
uh lived an apartment with like five
other guys and all of them decided to
get really into dark souls so we just
became like dark souls house
as you approach the house you just start
hearing the music just like right that
was a i turned the ball off a fog
machine at every door i turned the gas
on and they all came and sat around it
that was a weird apartment because also
uh one of my roommates was like crafting
his own beer uh in like the living room
he would just be like drinking his like
moonshine kind of whatever like ipa
craft beer and then just like playing
dark
oh my souls
sounds insane yeah it's a good time mine
was mass effect it wasn't years later
like i played mass effect when it came
out i was like i don't really know
and then i came back to it like a month
later and i was like ah
where it's just like kind of like
it's not very exciting for a very long
time
for me it was like i was i played it i
was like okay and then i had like some
mad [ __ ] happening in my life and i was
like
so i like shot all the lights and sat
down and then
and i was like this is different yeah oh
yeah that menu theme oh yeah
oh
and yeah that was it um that was a good
question though yeah i like that
question did we all answer it we all
answered it yeah yeah what was yours
uh mine was plague plagued on plateau
but not that i didn't like it um
yeah i mean like no one's no one's
trying to say uh mass effect sucks but
you know no
demon souls is terrible
relax
relax
[Laughter]
toddler over here
all right
thank you for
watching slash listening to the games
for after dark podcast live on twitch or
through your podcast server pre-recorded
in your ears pre-recorded in your ears
um
please if you are watching on twitch i'd
love it if you
hit follow we'd all love it if you hit
follow because that helps us you know
people want to see the numbers go up i
want to see the numbers go up but i
don't really mind i'm going to do this
all the time anyway we're all going to
be here that had like huge wolf of wall
street like
but there's at some point someone who's
got wearing a suit and is looking to
cause some problems he's gonna look and
be like how many numbers they got and
the more numbers we got the better it is
smash that follow button while you're
here um if you are listening in podca on
podcast services make sure to subscribe
and give a review
that same [ __ ] executive who's
looking for numbers is going to be again
he's looking for words
so if you if you're chucking some words
alongside it
that would be great
um and we should hopefully be yeah
i was looking to see if we had any new
reviews lucy playing the theme the
ending
yeah
uh we'll be back next week but before we
go
jean-luc where are people at where
people at where people at and
well the people should be at uh my
twitter account
john lennox
at john mcstepkey um what are you
working on
what am i working on i am working on i'm
working on that that game that i can't
talk about i'm working on that
how do i'm also
still working on this studio i promise
it is it is is growing in power yeah i'm
slowly at like i added headphones this
week yeah
the power play by behringer headphone
thingy thank you to jan mixing thank you
uh hydra
hydranox on on in the chat says magic
able
is following games for after on twitch a
good idea
you better fudge this
is it cocked
no
uh
it says big money big price
prizes
it definitely didn't say anything it
definitely didn't say game over
jordan where are you where can people
find you uh folks can find me on twitter
at jm mermaid please read my mad
ramblings about apex
it's going to it's doctor strange
supernatural arc it's exciting it's good
stuff
please read the uh please read my column
so that tam allows me to keep writing it
oh no i have become the number man yeah
holy [ __ ]
um lucy are you up to where can behind
you uh i'm working on some stuff that
you'll see in a few weeks time
um over on giant bomb jeff jasper's
adventure and a new episode of tivos
this week uh it's about minions i'm
really sorry
um
and then tam you and i are doing kind of
funny daily tomorrow yes i need to build
the script for that later today yes you
do please because i'm in a meeting 9 30
or 10 so i'm just gonna how how well
because i take all my work meetings on
here so i'll just log in on my no just
like how do you guys have time to do all
of um anything just don't sleep you know
i was going to make a harry potter
reference but you can't get the time
turner no that game's still coming out
this year no it doesn't yeah no every
time i blew up the epic game store it's
like please pre-order whatever and i was
like
i don't think i will
um
uh i'm yeah i'm everywhere twitter.com
slash loosejamsgames and i'm streaming
mass effect
because legendary edition was free uh
thanks to
thanks bezos box i guess amazon's free
service is literally called freeloading
which is like yeah yeah
yeah
that's the same energy as as as the
discord communication app which is a
word describing oh yeah things not going
well in communication it's like okay
cool yeah he's insulting me
anyways yeah um so you're streaming
mass effect and um
having a nice time doing it you love it
uh i'm on twitter uh tomorrow h um what
am i doing i
i put up some post about
nzxt's recent capture cards that they
sent me um the signal
uh hd60 and 4k30 which are surprisingly
good i don't know why i said
surprisingly they know a thing or two
about hardware but really that's where i
got my pc from yeah plug and play stuff
can they send us something for i don't
know
i don't know why they sent it to me
they're like you want to do this and i
was like okay all right whatever
i need do we need capture cards in here
we need some more capture cards in here
there's too many man
and zfc if you listen send us some
capture cards uh but yeah i did that and
then um
t boss is out now jeff jeff's is
happening
uh voice mode dump truck uh the latest
episode we're on as well um and then i'm
on twitch streaming resident evil and
probably gonna go on to something else
after that
um yeah should we do it should we do a
final question to
yeah the magic april um where's the
final question
the final question um chat ask one final
question for the magic 8 ball
make it a good one just you know what's
what's the week ahead gonna be like for
games
magic 8 ball are gamers going to behave
themselves in the following week
it could happen oh
let's go
that would be cool someone did actually
ask uh is metro prime 4 coming next year
see i was going to ask his holiday song
coming out next month it says red ring
of death oh sorry i'm sorry
we will see you next time next week same
place same channel
for games for off the dock
live enjoy your gaming happy gaming
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you